if this was a normal night I would be
with this man up it it's never it's
never normal that I would be with David
Shaw right in front of the fountains of
Bellagio in Las Vegas Nevada but if this
was a the draft night that we all
thought it would be I'd be getting set
to be on the air with this man on NFL
Network as he has been for I think eight
years and Counting
he is the head coach of Stanford
football David Shaw how are you David I
know well you know what well I think you
could be but me as an NFL employee David
I would have to apparently keep walking
all the way to the elevator banks and
hit a button unfortunately to go
straight but and I think we will be
there one day I think obviously the NFL
will put Vegas into the draft rotation
as soon as possible when we're back
living lives as normal as we possibly
can but as for tonight's draft the
question you just heard is our poll
question today for a reason because I
think that is the crux of tonight's
Draft where tour goes would you agree
with that assessment David Shaw yeah I
mean every every team has to find out
what were their risk with what risk they
want to take and it's really tough to
say if you believe there's any chance
that he is not healthy enough to truly
compete year one that you've draft him
that high but if you say you know what
long term wise we think he's going to be
the guy this is our guy we've fallen in
love with them in our meetings we fall
in love with this film if he's not 100
percent year one but ready to go year
two and be the franchise guy that we
want then you don't hesitate but those
are the questions that have to be
answered and I'm not in those rooms so I
can't say 100% but if I was I would have
to feel very very good especially as a
general manager that this guy is not
only going to be the guy but he's gonna
actually be the guy sometime the next
year or so and he's not going to be on
the Shelf because I know my job is on
the line by making this pick so let's
let's let's hypothetical this thing out
best we can because what you know and
what I know apparently is what the
team's know all right because they they
clearly don't have the ability to get
their own doctor to go take a look at -
they have
the medicals of the recheck apparently
that went very well for him after the
combine checked that took place on him
no doubt so if you get those things in
and the eye in the sky that you have
seen for this young man and then you
have had the ability to obviously face
to face it with him and you do see the
video that Trent Dilfer and of him being
put through the paces by Trent Dilfer
and Ken Whisenhunt and spoke to those
guys would you be comfortable that way
in making that decision for tua atop
this draft third or fifth overall if I
got that information and what I've seen
on film I would not hesitate this guy
throws a ball in tight windows he's got
quick feet but he's not fast to escape
the pocket he's got great savvy he's one
heck of a football player and I think
he's gonna play really well in the next
level there will be teams that looking
at it the same you know what gosh if I
can take a guy like Justin Herbert that
has no physical to no physical ills at
all but still the top line passer you
know I would just feel more comfortable
with that so that's why those teams have
to make those calls but if I got that
information on tour I turn the card in
and high-five everybody in the room not
more elbow bump right so let's put a pin
in Herbert for a second because clearly
you've you've got a lot of history of
seeing him with your own two eyes and
having to watch your defense and the
rest of the room game plan for him let's
now I pathetical this in the evaluation
of tool and burrow
if you believe burrow is that much
better than tool would you if you are
Miami give the so called Godfather offer
to Cincinnati which would be I imagine
every single one of your first round
selections all three of them to go move
up and go get them would you do that
just from my my nine years in the NFL
and and doing this with you all for so
long yeah I that's never worth it you
end up you end up with a great player
and nobody to put around them for the
next few years
and I think it's usually bad for your
team and it's bad for that player so I
personally never feel good about those
big time blockbuster trades okay
put a little bit more meat on the bones
III think it's obvious than the fact
that you you say you doin Kane surround
them with others of first round talent
but walk me through a unpacked that one
a little bit more for me David unpack
that answer a little bit more put a
little bit more meat on the bones about
why you think that that wouldn't be
worth it I mean if the kid is that good
if he could be the next you know what
eventually you can surround him right
yeah you know I just I just picture a
picture with Ricky Williams sitting at
that at that table after the New Orleans
draft where they traded everything for
them and how difficult those those next
few years were I think about the
Herschel Walker trade you know trading
away so much you're helping the team
that you're trading with really build
and what I watch the Patriots do what i
watch the Colts do for all those years
just constantly putting pieces around
when I watched Pete Carroll and Snyder
do with Seattle with a bunch of third
fourth and fifth round picks it to me
it's the accumulation of picks that
truly helped build a championship team
and I would hate to give away a bunch of
pigs for one player Stanford Cardinal
head football coach David Shaw
you mentioned nine years in the NFL
Ravens and and Raiders correct that's
who you spent those times with don't
forget the cup of coffee in Philadelphia
right here on the Rich Eisen show okay
Justin Herbert what's your evaluation of
him and his readiness or success level
in the NFL every single box is checked
besides athletic ability arm strength he
is streaky accuracy wise the guy can
make some special special place and I
know from I've heard from other people
and watching their film that you wonder
you don't see the Joe burrow take the
game over to or take the game over you
don't see him do that as much as those
other those other teams those other guys
would do those other teams but I think
in the right situation this guy can
either come in early or come in and sit
and watch but I think the ceiling is
very very high give me a righteous
situation for him what do you think
great situation for a young quarterback
for me
starts with a great defense and a
running game so that now all the
pressures on his shoulders so that he
can kind of get his feet wet and
hopefully at some point B be the guy and
take it over you hate to have a rookie
go out there and you heard you know so
Peyton Manning's quotes about his rookie
year that were great for him but it was
a lot of difficult hard tough lessons
because it was on his shoulders from day
one you know throwing the ball between
30 and 45 times a game is really really
tough for a young guy when you've got
defensive specialists out there that are
that are going to give him things that
he's never seen before so you'd love to
have the pieces around them it's the
easiest way in and play but still be
protected upfront protected by a running
game be protected by his defense how
would you evaluate Sam Donald right now
David you're three now going in his
team's hope you see the the training
wheels come off you hope to see him get
comfortable and and play at a high level
I know they've had some turnover there
at the receiver position I think that
he's played well in spurts and it's hard
to truly judge is it you know not enough
that team's not good enough around him
etc but I think for him he's shown those
flashes of what we saw at USC but this
is this is where it's got to start to
turn for him and for the franchise for
him to truly be that franchise
quarterback and take this team to the
playoffs I know you were high on him at
that draft in Dallas that year and you
were one of them members of the panel
that was scratching your head a little
bit at Mayfield you like Mayfield a lot
but first overall of somebody that you
know wasn't much taller than six feet do
you think you could make an assessment
on Mayfield right now my system Mayfield
has remained the same as him coming out
of college which is when you watch the
great plays you say wow he's a
combination of Drew Brees and Russell
Wilson and when you watch the bad plays
you say oh my gosh does this kid
understand he can't throw the ball in to
triple coverage you know but if there's
a lot on his plate he's trying so hard
and you never fault him for his effort
his toughness his competitiveness you
know at times he needs a little bit more
discretion but that's what young
quarterbacks you kind of need to play
their way
into and we can talk also puppy the
interviews and some of the things he
says that you kind of cringe and say oh
gosh you know we want you to be the
franchisee and washer what's your your
your words a little bit better because
everybody's looking at you the entire
organization is leaning on you and
that's what we talked about being a
franchise quarterback it's not just
about the quarterback on the field it's
about being the the biggest spokesman
for your team and I think he's got some
room to grow there I do think he's
improved but he's got a lot of room to
grow as far as turning the ball over and
truly being that franchise quarterback
and last one on the quarterback
situation throat Trevor Lawrence in this
mix where does he stand for you prospect
wise amongst all this quarterback class
2020 if he was in it you you'd say what
there would be some discussion but I
think the fact that he would have maybe
a little bit stronger arm than Joe about
a few inches taller just too good of an
athlete if not a little bit better
athlete
I think he'd go number one I think the
guy's got he's got that it factor just
like Joe does just like to it does but
this guy is big he's tall he's long he's
fast he's explosive he's a great
competitor
watching him get knocked out of the game
and then come back and still put his
shoulder down and try to run people over
and make some big-time throws this guy's
answered all the questions David Shaw of
Stanford couple minutes left with him
here on the Rich Eisen show I know you
love talking receivers whenever you're
on the draft set with us our buddy mike
Mayock
12th overall for the Raiders sure looks
like he can make his first draft choices
the Las Vegas Raiders GM his pick of any
wide receiver on the board if you had
that choice you would choose who that
would be a tough we'd have to battle
this in the room I love Jerry Judy
because I love guys that can run routes
and run every single route in the book
the name of the game is separation and
he can get separation right now day one
as a rookie receiver that would be tough
to pass up but then I'd look at his
teammate rug's also and say this guy is
like he'll from Kansas City
you have to count for me can score from
any place on every
play that to me would be the discussion
between those two guys because they are
both game changers yeah I know
Daniel Jeremiah says it's go CD lamb
Justin Jefferson how about that the
exact opposite of what you said that's
what he thinks it does six guys in this
in his first round that it could be
special and I but I love the quickness
of Judy CD lamb is special after the
catch he ran a four or 500 at the
combine but he seems to run past
everybody and he's a big guy he's strong
he's physical
I love Justin Jefferson his ability to
get open versus one-on-one and if he's
not open he just takes the ball away
from me anyway those two guys are
special as well so who's the other so
you like are you occur with the other
two receivers that you you give a
first-round grade to I love a guy that
just gets the ball much like rugs and as
soon as he touches the ball he's making
decisions in his head at a high rate of
speed to just score that's all he's
trying to do he's trying to break
tackles make people miss he turns short
passes into long gains as receivers code
as a receiver coach as a coordinator as
a head coach those are guys that you're
looking for to where the quarterback can
get the ball out of his hands and we can
still get a big play very quickly all
right ask the poll question if David
Shaw before we send him on into his good
draft day go for it Christmas all right
coach who takes two tonight the Dolphins
the Chargers or he falls I keep looking
at and I just can't see Miami past them
I keep saying Miami I do too I do too I
mean they did all this work and by work
I mean sending away Tunsil sending away
Minka Fitzpatrick sending away Kenyan
Drake I mean name the people that they
have just let go essentially to prepare
for this moment and and Ryan Fitzpatrick
almost botched it because he refuses to
tank that man will never take you know
look at them it's a newer head coach
they have long vision and and this you
look at him and this is a franchise guys
he's healthy and they and they have the
proof that he believed he's going to be
healthy
you have the long vision and you throw
in the pic and you know that in the next
couple years you may have a special
player
so tor doesn't have that hip injury and
it's just him straight up with burrow
even though we saw them play against
each other straight up in boroughs
remarkable season what's your evaluation
what do you do
I really would I love Joe's accuracy I
love his playmaking ability I love his
toughness I think too is there's a
little bit extra their aesthetic ly in
my opinion but not one not to run but to
make those ridiculous throws on the run
that he can make they both were
surrounded by outstanding talent but
both guys made plays and I would
probably choose to by the way I lied I
got one more for you when you're in the
draft room with Ozzie Newsome what's the
proudest pounding at the table you had
and then Ozzy said okay I'll take that
guy which one master his draft process
was phenomenal he weeded out all the
things beforehand and he would put all
the guys in one long line and he could
manipulate the draft like nobody I've
ever seen he took in a lot of people's
input but he would remind us all the
time the draft day was his game day
which means you know what was our game
day he gets to watch on his game day we
get to watch is that right I'm a draft
day without his game day there's no
question about it
and we would everybody had a little bit
influence but he was going to make the
call and and he's he's a hall-of-famer
as a player and he's a hall-of-famer as
a GM and the more a mother of all
going-away presents lamar jackson his
last first-round draft choice that's it
you take care of yourself David I'll
miss you tonight but let's so let's stay
in touch okay
neither man that's David Shaw of
Stanford Cardinal head football coach
love having him on the draft set love it
love it love it
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here